next a forum on the future of urban
development
city officials from around the nation
gathered this week in the nation's
capital to discuss the possibility of
developing 24-hour downtown urban
centers
kathy merritt of washington dc's wamu
radio moderated this discussion hosted
by the brookings institution
[Applause]
good morning again
my name is ann wheelock and i'm the
president of the fannie mae foundation
welcome to the second annual james w
rouse forum on the american cities
it's hosted by the fannie mae foundation
the enterprise foundation
and the brookings institution center on
urban and metropolitan policy
i am so glad you could join us today for
our celebration of our country's great
urban centers
but more importantly
to celebrate the legacy of jim rouse
jim's vision and life's work
is very much alive and well
as we witness city renewal
and community revitalization
across the country
the theme of this year's forum
is the future of the american downtown
building a 24-hour center
throughout the united states central
business districts have experienced a
remarkable resurgence in commercial
cultural
and entertainment activity
cities
including our own district of columbia
and a city of special focus today denver
colorado
have built new sports complexes
waterfronts aquariums
amusement parks convention centers
and other attraction attractions to lure
new residents and businesses to our
city's centers
today
we will highlight cutting edge
strategies
which the private sector
and local government leaders
have employed to transform america's
downtowns
i hope you will find today interesting
thought provoking
and enjoyable
although the audience is filled with
important dignitaries and guests i would
like to take a moment
to recognize two very special foreign
participants
paddy rouse
jim rouse's trusted partner
best friend and wife
patty joined us last year and is again
with us today
during jim's life
and now
patti is very much at the heart of the
work of the enterprise foundation
she takes personal interest
in the communities that the foundation
serves and works closely with enterprise
staff
working tirelessly to assist low-income
individuals
and families
to find secure
fit and affordable housing
patty
thank you so much for all the good work
that you do did you stand so that we can
recognize you
[Applause]
[Applause]
ted rouse
jim rouse's son
will also be joining us today as well
ted rouse has very much followed in his
father's footsteps
we appreciate his good efforts to build
affordable housing
for americans across the country
we thank him for joining us and
celebrating his father's life ted are
you here could you stand please
thank you
[Music]
i now have the honor of introducing to
you the chairman and chief executive
officer of the enterprise foundation
bart harvey
many of you are probably very familiar
with the enterprise foundation after all
it has worked with almost nine hundred
fifty non-profit organizations
in over two hundred eighty locations
across america
providing over two point three billion
dollars
that's two point three billion dollars
in grants loans and equity investments
to help produce or renovate over eighty
six thousand homes and apartments for
low low-income individuals and families
however many of you may not know how
bart harvey came to the enterprise
foundation
bart first met jim rouse in 1984.
at that time bart agreed to volunteer at
the enterprise foundation
for one year
but because bart was infected by jim
rouse's enthusiasm
and optimism
bart never left the enterprise
foundation
and is now leading the organization to
new heights
i i have had the good fortune
of knowing and working with bart harvey
for over six years
i have been impressed not only with
bart's intellect
after all he did serve as the managing
director for the corporate finance
division for dean witter reynolds
but i have truly been struck
by his focus
his drive
his mission to help others help
themselves
bart harvey is truly an inspiration
his love
and work
of humanity is almost
spiritual
i am privileged to present to you the
chairman and ceo of the enterprise
foundation bart harvey
thank you anne-marie
for that wonderful introduction and i'd
say in you
the fannie mae foundation has a new
leader of great strength and commitment
and ability
i'd like to also add
to anne marie's comments how delighted i
am that teddy rouse could be here today
and to say to patty rouse that we at the
enterprise foundation owe you a great
debt of gratitude for your continuing
work for keeping the vision of jim rouse
every day patti's there and she lets us
know that
jim wanted to serve
the very poor people in this country and
that we ought to stick to that mission
thank you patty
uh
the enterprise foundation is delighted
to be a sponsor of this with the fannie
mae foundation and brookings institute
we simply couldn't be in better company
and i also want to salute jim johnson
for creating and naming this forum
after jim rouse
and for approaching it with jim's spirit
and can do attitude
in fact
jim rouse would be very pleased today
that so many of you who care about and
are influencing our cities
are here
with us today
jim said from the cover of time magazine
in 1981 cities are fun
and we are heartened by the reports from
the brookings institute picked up by the
economist magazine that shows that
downtowns are up
right now in so many cities
you'll hear a lot more about that later
in the panel program
on the same cover of time jim rouse was
labeled a master planner
and uh it will be a great honor to hear
from the acclaimed historian and writer
robert caro
about the legacy of the master builder
of all of our time robert moses
and i think it's the 100th anniversary
of the unification of new york city in
25 years since robert carroll
wrote so elegant eloquently and well
about robert moses
but let me say that there is a great
difference in point of view between
these great urban visionaries jim rouse
and robert moses jim rouse's philosophy
summed up
in a quote from him the only legitimate
purpose
of a city
is to provide for the life and growth of
its people
and jim rouse spent
his professional life pursuing those
ideals and goals in fact
he worked on his vision and belief that
there is a vibrant heart in our
downtowns
and that we ought to
emphasize and bring forth the best of
our downtowns in all of our cities
but he also
set up the enterprise foundation to
provide opportunity for poor people in
the neighborhood surrounding those
downtowns
so that those people would have decent
affordable housing and a path up and out
of poverty into the mainstream of life
he clearly believed
what ought to be can be if you if you
have the will to make it so
whereas that great mayor of one of the
most progressive cities in the world
kuratiba brazil
mayor
mayor jaime lerner said trend is not
destiny
and i think all of us are here
with those words in mind with strong
leaders with good policies
and the power of public will
our urban areas can reverse their
negative trends many of them are already
it's also fitting
that our afternoon discussion will focus
on denver it's a city with deep roots
for the enterprise foundation our first
grant
was received from sam very of the piton
foundation of denver in 1981
and our first grantee or one of our
first grantees
was an energetic minister ray stransky
from hope communities in denver and ray
stransky took our grant
and his organization has built over 500
units of decent housing for very poor
people and he continues to transform the
community in which he's working in
denver
in just 33 days we will also be seeing
our good friend
mayor webb as we bring a thousand
500 community development practitioners
to end their expendable dollars
to
downtown to lower downtown denver
uh for our annual network conference
this is the largest such conference um
in the country
and our discussion in denver
will go well beyond bricks and mortars
to people and possibilities
and it is in that spirit and sense that
we approach this forum today thank you
very much
[Applause]
it's now a great pleasure for me to
introduce
a true friend of the american city and
an extraordinary leader
jim johnson chairman and ceo of fannie
mae and chairman of the fannie mae
foundation
shortly after taking the helm at fannie
mae
jim emerged as the most significant
private sector leader in housing and
housing finance
and he did that by dedicating fannie mae
and the housing industry
to reducing housing costs
eliminating discrimination
and expanding opportunities for the
millions of americans who dream of
owning their own home
in fact within 45 days he had set upon a
major initiative to expand affordable
housing at fannie mae trumped only by
his trillion dollar
campaign and initiative that fannie mae
is fulfilling right now
there is a wonderful couplet from girder
that jim rouse loved and acted on
and it is so appropriate for jim johnson
the couplet goes like this
whatever you can do
or dream you can
begin it boldness has genius power and
magic in it
and
boldness genius power and magic are
hallmarks of jim johnson's leadership at
fannie mae along with
careful organization hard work and
extraordinary stamina
in his book
showing america new way home published
two years ago jim johnson envisioned a
time where there will be millions quote
millions of additional homeowners
responding to a mortgage lending
industry that actively seeks their
business and offers mortgage finance
options
to meet their unique needs
fannie mae is
truly showing us the way home on that
vision
jim's
deep commitment to his work and his
sense of direction shows through and
again
you can see it in another quote from his
book quote
so much of our identity so much so many
of our hopes are contained in the
ambition to own our own homes from the
start for america
a home has been more than another asset
has been a motivating idea a nearly
universal goal
the most individual of possessions and
the most shared american dreams
and that is what we also believe at the
enterprise foundation
jim i think i speak for everybody in the
room today and commending you for your
extraordinary leadership
of fannie mae
your commitment to helping people from
all walks of life and your use of power
and author and authority to help others
you have led fannie mae with great
integrity and boldness jim johnson
[Applause]
thank you very much bart like to welcome
all of you here this morning
this is my first time in this building
and it's answered a question for me and
that is that i think we now know
what the taj mahal would have looked
like if only had been properly funded
the i'd also like to say a word of thank
you
since so many of you have already
commented on it to my friend dennis
archer
for giving me this tie
this is a tie the design of which is
completely controlled by the mayor of
detroit
he has all of the ties and he gives them
out to his friends and it's impossible
to buy one anywhere
but a lot of people wondered whether or
not i had a significant personality
change just in the last few days
i'd like to uh
give a special uh additional word of
welcome to patty rouse thank you so much
for being with us again
to teddy rouse thank you for coming
uh i also want to say a word about ann
wheeler the president of fannie mae
foundation
and we're delighted uh with your
leadership we're delighted with the
transition uh and we have absolutely no
doubt
uh that
with your leadership the fannie mae
foundation will be even more effective
than it's been in the past so thank you
for all that you're doing
we've got a lot of thank yous and
introductions this morning but i'll try
to move through them as fast as i can
i want to say a word about
mike armacost who's just finishing his
third year as president of the brookings
institution
uh before mike came to brookings uh
there wasn't a focus on urban
metropolitan policy there was no special
research unit
and in mike starting this program and
hiring bruce katz the director of the
center on urban and metropolitan policy
uh brookings is now playing a major role
in the academic underpinnings of this
field uh working hard uh sponsoring a
wide variety of research inquiries uh
and thank you both mike and bruce for
being here and for the work
that you're doing uh bart harvey and
enterprise are well known to all of you
uh it's always such a pleasure to be
with bart because he is so fresh and and
so uh committed to the work that he's
doing and doing it so effectively i'd
also like to introduce part of our team
from fannie mae
uh our president larry small is here and
jamie gerelich our vice chair
both members of the board of directors
of the company as well as members of the
board of the fannie mae foundation there
are a number of other members of the
board of the fannie mae foundation here
but larry jamie and the other members of
the board would you just stand for a
minute so we could pay tribute to you as
well
many of you know
that i am bringing to a close my time at
fannie mae
on january 1 i will be succeeded by
frank raines
uh frank many of you know because he
played such
a vital role when he was in president
clinton's cabinet of transforming the
future of the district of columbia
he worked at fannie mae for five years
before going into the president's
cabinet uh he is as vice chair
uh he is going to do a fabulous job
and now you'll i think finally get a
glimpse of what fannie mae and the
fannie mae foundation
will be like with truly exceptional
leadership frank reigns
[Applause]
we are here today in a very real sense
because jim rouse brought us here
jim's vision and his energy were never
more evident than when he focused on how
and where people lived
his legacy lives on in places like
columbia maryland baltimore's harbor
place faneuil hall marketplace in boston
and it lives on and the people gathered
here today
men and women who devote their ideas and
their enthusiasm to the future of the
american city
the future of american cities would look
which looked so bleak just a few years
ago
now appears very bright indeed
the current economic expansion the third
longest in american history has helped
restore cities to fiscal health
new jobs have been created the average
unemployment rate in cities is just over
five percent
down from 8.2 as recently as 1993.
in the past few years
i've visited virtually every major
american city
and in each one i've seen
very tangible signs of urban rebirth
i've seen new entertainment districts
business centers sports complex tourist
attractions and in many cases new
manufacturing jobs as well
these developments are helping to
reclaim the city's historic role as
centers of culture and commerce
the american city is not and never has
been simply a workplace
or a playground
it is first and foremost a hometown
the future of the american city depends
on our ability to integrate all three of
these roles
workplace playground and hometown
into coherent and viable whole
simply put if we are to sustain and
expand the remarkable progress we have
made
we must firmly link downtown to hometown
so that our cities are diverse
vibrant and alive 24 hours a day
many cities are already doing important
work to stabilize and expand their
residential base
and to create living downtowns
mayors and community leaders who know
that home ownership anchors
neighborhoods and leads to greater
family stability
less crime
better schools are working with us and
with many others to make it possible for
more people to buy homes
in the city
they are reclaiming abandoned and vacant
lots
developing mixed use and low density
apartment complexes and together with
long-time residents and new immigrants
they are rebuilding areas once lost to
decay and despair
their work is bearing fruit
a new survey conducted by the brookings
institution center on urban metropolitan
policy
and the fannie mae foundation in
preparation for this forum
shows that a population boom
is taking place in many downtowns across
the country
this trend is evident in cities with
established downtown residential
districts
and those with almost no history
of downtown domestic life
cities that have lost population for
decades
like philadelphia chicago and columbus
now expect that the number of people
living in their downtown areas will rise
chicago expects a 32 percent increase in
its downtown population in the next
decade
in new york
the wall street area is becoming a
thriving residential center
with vacant office space being converted
into apartments
the city expects an 80 percent increase
in downtown residents by 2010.
in houston young couples and empty
nesters attracted to the city's
amenities and location have contributed
to a rise in downtown population over
the past three years
are expected to lead the way to a
quadrupling
of the number of people living downtown
over the next dozen years
and in denver the home of our luncheon
speaker mayor wellington webb
downtown condominiums apartments and
townhouses are leased or sold as quickly
as they are built the city has made a
concerted effort to ensure
the economic and social diversity of its
downtown area
by 2010 the downtown population in
denver is expected to increase by
133 percent
our purpose today
is to take a closer look at the emerging
urban renaissance
to examine the underlying trends
and to gain a greater understanding of
how to create a living downtown
our speakers and our panelists all have
unique and interesting insights into the
future of the american city
i don't believe though that we could
have chosen a more fitting
and fascinating individual to be this
year's rouse lecturer
than robert carroll
he is the pulitzer prize winning
biographer
of robert moses the master builder of
new york city which this year celebrates
its 100th anniversary as a consolidated
city
his biography entitled the power broker
robert moses and the fall of new york
also is having an anniversary its 25th
and interestingly enough has just gone
into its 35th
continuous printing
in 25 years the book has never been out
of print which is truly remarkable
mr carroll also is the biographer of
president lyndon johnson
and is working on an eagerly anticipated
third volume of that series
the first two volumes the path to power
published in 1982
and means of ascent published in 1990
each won
the coveted national book critics circle
award for biography
robert carroll really revolutionizes the
genre of biography through his artful
writing daring analysis
and in-depth reporting
the washington post placed carol quote
at the summit of american historical
writing unquote
but our speaker has said that he is not
interested in writing the biographies of
famous men
but really in how political power works
that interest led him to his first
subject robert moses
moses shaped new york city
into a tarot term a colossus a colossal
synthesis of urban hope
and urban despair
he became the most powerful figure not
only in new york city but also new york
state for over 40 years
more powerful than any mayor
and governor combined
robert carroll has compared moses to the
pharaohs
the caesars
and the donald
trump that is
carol recently told npr
that robert moses was the greatest
physical builder in the history of the
world
and added quote
it would take about a dozen donald
trumps
working for a hundred years to equal the
output of robert moses
even moses's biggest critic for 30 years
the urban planner and writer louis
mumford
said
in the 20th century the influence of
robert moses on the cities of america
was greater
than any other single person
so we're delighted to have his
biographer address our forum on cities
in the 21st century
a forum honoring another visionary
builder jim rouse
we're especially pleased that robert
carroll will take questions
after he concludes his remarks so that
is a tip of course for all of you to
have questions ready
in a moment he'll tell you about robert
moses but first let me tell you just a
little bit more about robert carroll
he shares credit for the meticulous and
voluminous research
that goes into his books
with his one and only researcher aina
his wife for 41 years
it's no surprise that he was originally
an investigative port reporter mainly
for newsday on long island from 1960 to
1966
serving his final year as a neiman
fellow
at harvard
he's a native new yorker
reported for the new brunswick home news
in new jersey for two years after
graduating [ __ ] laude from princeton
university in 1957.
he's been an avid runner for more than
30 years
and he outlines each day's work in his
head while running around the central
park reservoir path
please welcome robert carroll
[Applause]
well the way things seem to have worked
out in america today if you're a writer
you spend a lot of time giving speeches
however i'm always more at ease uh
writing than speaking i'm always feel
more at home in front of my typewriter
than in front of a lectern in fact every
time i get up to speak no matter how
often i do it i still feel like the
young rabbi jewish like me just gotten
out of rabbinical school and he
now assigned as the assistant rabbi to
his first congregation and after a few
months the senior rabbi says to him next
friday night you're going to give your
first sermon
the young rabbi says well you know i
have to confess to you that i'm
get very nervous when i talk in public
do you have any advice for me the older
rabbi says well you know you're allowed
to have a water glass up there on the
pulpit with you and i find that it helps
if i fill it with a very dry martini
so the young rabbi takes the advice and
gives his sermon at the end of it he
hurries to the back of the synagogue and
he says to the older rabbi
how'd i do
the older rabbi says well i have three
comments to make
first when i told you you could have
that water glass up there and open in
the full view of the whole congregation
and fill it with a martini i didn't mean
you should keep the olive in it
he said
second
i suggested that you sip the martini at
crucial points in your
sermon not drink the entire thing at the
beginning in one huge gulp
and third david slew goliath
he didn't beat the [ __ ] out of him
despite that
this talk today is one that i'm really
very pleased to have been asked to give
because i've been asked to talk about
what america's cities now in the midst
of what is really a remarkable
resurgency true renaissance
what they can learn from the legacy of
robert moser and in my opinion they can
learn quite a lot
because the legacy he left is a very
large one with some very striking
lessons
on both sides of the ledger robert moses
was a true city shaper and the city he
shaped was new york the titan of city he
left quite a mark
and he left it on the greatest city in
the western world what is the mark of
robert moses well
you can see it
any time you fly into new york if you're
flying in from the north the laguardia
airport your plane will probably pass
over the throgs and that bridge robert
moses built that then over the bronx
white stone bridge you built that then
over the triborough bridge he built that
and then in making its approach it will
turn around over the henry hudson bridge
and robert moses built that too if
you're flying in from the south you fly
over the great verrazano narrows bridge
which he built then over the cross bay
boulevard bridge the marine parkway
bridge is all built by the same man
as you come in over the city you will
see this a city with a very rigid grid
pattern of individual streets and they
look very small but cutting across this
grid are huge swaths of concrete
with a these are the highways
with the single exception of one highway
the east river drive every major road
that you see was built by this one man
robert moses he built 16 expressways and
14 parkways
627 miles of arterial roads
there's a lot of green that you can see
from the air
much of it was created by robert motion
he added twenty thousand acres of parks
within the city's borders and forty
thousand acres in its suburbs sixty
thousand new acres and in fact every
piece of green that you see at one time
boy the mark of robert moses because
what he didn't create he recreated
reshaping every park in the city during
his decades as park commissioner
and bridges
highways and parks are only a part in a
small part of what robert moses built
when he controlled the new york city
housing authority that authority built
1082 separate apartment houses
containing 148 000 apartments which
housed 555
000 people
more people than lived at that time in
the city of minneapolis when he would
talk to me about that he considered that
such a minor item he would barely bother
to list it in his list of achievements
he had the vision for used his power to
clear away entire neighborhoods to
create and in many cases built some of
the greatest
uh monuments in new york lincoln center
the united nations shea stadium the
coliseum
he changed the very borders of new york
he hammered bulkheads uh off into the
waters off the shores of new york he
filled the areas between the bulkheads
and the land with rocks and stones and
concrete and sand
planted grass on top of them
and created fifteen thousand acres of
new land in the city as jim said
he was in my opinion the greatest
builder in the history of america
certainly
and possibly the greatest builder in the
history of the world
he held power in new york city and new
york state for almost half a century the
city is now as dimension celebrating its
100th anniversary during those hundred
years robert moses was in power for
almost half of them for 44 years from
1924 to 1968.
he held this power under the
administrations of five mayors laguardia
o'dwyer and paluteri robert wagner and
john lindsay he held it during the
administrations of six governors al
smith franklin roosevelt herbert lehman
thomas dewey avril harriman and nelson
rockefeller and in the fields in which
he chose to exercise that power as jim
said
he had more power
not uh than any mayor any governor in
the state or city government or state
and city governments combined
and this power was not confined to
public works it went far beyond that
because robert moses did not shape the
city merely physically decade after
decade he played a crucial role often
the decisive role in establishing the
city's priorities and policies in
creating not merely its physical but its
social fabric
who is this man who did so much
well
when i started i was still a reporter
when i started researching the power
broker i really had
no idea the only robert moses i knew was
the robert moses i had gotten to know as
a reporter the robert moses some of us
remember he was the robert moses of the
huge title one scandal
where he condemned entire neighborhoods
of the city including areas that were
not slums at all but viable lively
neighborhoods and turn them over to
political machines into the contractors
architects insurance brokers lawyers
public relations firms etc profit
allowing them to milk these
neighborhoods for years instead of
developing them and creating in the
process vast new slums it was the robert
moses who kept building expressways and
more expressways highway after highway
after highway and a frantic attempt to
end the traffic problem while
simultaneously starving systematically
starving the mass transit system the
subways and the commuter railroads
starving them decade after decade
refusing to listen to urban planners who
decade after decade we're trying to tell
him that without mass transit
no amount of highways can solve urban
traffic problems and he is the robert
moses who to clear paths for his
expressways and his urban renewal
projects evicted from their homes a
number of people whose number cannot
ever be accurately determined but that
by the most conservative estimates with
certainly more than half a million
people and who concentrated on evicting
blacks hispanics and the poor
because they were the most defenseless
stanley isaacs a borough president with
a social conscience once conducted his
own investigation of the methods by
which robert moses removed people from
the path of his highways and concluded
he hounded them out like cattle
when i started my research on the power
broker that was the robert moses i knew
the only robert moses i knew but i
hadn't been doing uh research very long
when i came across a very different
robert moses the young robert moses the
idealist the dreamer the reformer
i learned about him first just by
happenstance because someone told me
that francis perkins who was later
franklin roosevelt's secretary of labor
had left in oral history and i went up
to columbia to read it and i found that
in 1913 and 14 she was robert moses's
friend
and in fact
they would spend weekends walking around
the city together and she wrote
everything bob saw walking around the
city made him think of some way it could
be better
he was burning up with ideas just
burning up with him
one of the things he was looking at he
lived on the west side and at night he
was then 26 years old he was working as
a very low level researcher for a
municipal reform organization and at
night when he would come home to the
west side he would tell the taxi driver
to drive him all the way over to
riverside drive
where he would look down
on the hudson river and what was next to
it what was next to it was really an
immense mud flat six miles long really
not much more than a wasteland
the city had turned over that area which
was below the cliffs of riverside drive
to the new york central railroad decades
before the railroad had put four
railroad lines along it they had walled
off the lines with high barbed wire
fences so the city was completely shut
off for its water and all day and night
you long trains endless trains carrying
pigs and cattle south to the
slaughterhouses sat in south in the
south of manhattan would pass the
lawyers and since these trains were
powered by oil or coal
a continual smog very black accurate
gritty dense would always hover over
this park rising up toward the apartment
houses it was really a wasteland the
only things that were in it beside the
railroad tracks were immense garbage
dumps because that's where the city
dumped its garbage while waiting for the
scours to take it out to sea and shanty
towns in which lived derelict and at
night the residents of the apartment
houses could look down and see the fires
of the uh derelicts down there the
shanty towns were considered so
uh dangerous that even the police tried
to stay away from them one day in 1914
francis perkins and robert moses and a
group of friends are going to a picnic
in new jersey and they're going by a
ferry the ferry stands out into the
river so that this wasteland spreads out
behind them with the smoke hanging over
and all of a sudden francis perkins
hears the young man beside her say
francis
isn't this a temptation to you
couldn't this waterfront be the most
beautiful thing in the world
and she said he had it all figured out
how you could cover the tracks with this
great highway that ran up town along the
water now you'd have to bring it around
the curve at 72nd street and knock down
some buildings there now next to the
highway you could have this great park
filled with baseball diamonds tennis
courts bicycle pairs marinas would be on
the waterfront for sailboats and the
thing that got francis perkins that
impressed to the most was in her words
he had it all figured out
down to the location of the tennis
courts and the baseball diamonds the man
beside her was a low-level researcher at
a reform organization
he had envisioned an urban improvement
that would dwarf anything ever built in
america and he had it figured out during
the late down to the last detail when
you see riverside park in the west side
highway today
you are looking at robert moses young
dream which he finally got to build in
1937
more than 20 years after he had dreamed
it the young robert moses was a
visionary a dreamer a dreamer who was a
young researcher was dreaming dreams on
an unheard of scale when i finally got
to talk to robert moses
during the brief time i got to talk to
him those interviews didn't go on very
long
i can tell you you could see that
visionary that idealist in each of his
offices
uh there was an immense map of new york
and its suburbs when he wanted to tell
you about something he would jump up he
was then in his late 70s like a young
boy
with a yellow pencil in his hand and
start waving it around and say can't you
see the highway ought to be there
because if we put it there it will put
the parks over there we'll have a small
park here then we can have the public
housing over here he reminded me of an
artist standing in front of an easel
and the picture he was painting
was immense in scope because he saw this
whole area as one as the pencil would
move over it he would talk about suffolk
county and staten island manhattan and
montauk soho and scarsdale in the same
sentences he saw
you saw he saw this entire area
2100 square miles not in just new york
but at suburbs an area which at that
time 14 million people live as a single
uh whole
and he wanted to design it and spend 44
years of his life designing it as a
single unified whole when he would tell
me things about how he dreamed of jones
beach the bathing beach there when he
came across it one day when he was out
on the great south bay alone and a
little motorboat stepped onto this
deserted sandbar where there wasn't a
single human being it was just thrilling
to hear
new york city is filled with the wonders
of robert moses so one of the lessons
that in my opinion needs to be learned
from the lesson
legacy of robert moses is the need if
you're dealing with a city a vision on a
grand scale
the modern cities of the 21st century
will need that kind of vision an ability
to see and a willingness a drive to
create improvements on the scale a
modern city will need
but of course
as those of you who have read my book no
that is not at all
the only lesson that needs to be learned
from the legacy of robert moses
that is only one aspect of his mark
and it is not at all the most important
aspect
for a while in the beginning the power
that robert moses amassed
and he had a genius for amassing power
was the servant of his dreams and he
wanted power so he could turn these
dreams into reality
power is not a weapon that can be used
with impunity it's a drug it's a drug
that it's very addictive it requires
larger and larger doses if it's a weapon
it's a very unusual weapon if you say
it's a sword it's a sword
whose handle whose hilt as well as the
blade is razor sharp so that as it is
used on people it cuts into the person
using it as well as into the people on
whom it is used and changes him
and it worked that effect on robert
moses
little by little as decade followed
decade there came a change
slowly but inexorably moses began to
seek power for its own sake more and
more the criterion by which he selected
which public works would be built came
to be not the needs of the city's people
but the amount of new power a project
could give him increasingly the projects
became not ends but means the means of
obtaining more and more power and more
and more
what vanished from his vision and his
concerns
with the city's people
as people
concerns with human needs
with human values
he built decade after decade bigger and
bigger projects with an increasing
callousness toward the people for whom
he was supposedly building them
so there is another side to the legacy
of robert moses
one way of looking at that legacy
is to look at how in creating his vast
transportation system he treated the
people of the city the people who stood
in the way of his highways
for the mark of robert moses has quite a
bit to do with the way he treated those
people
moses built
627 miles of highways in new york
130 miles of them were expressways the
massive roads that he rammed right
through the heart of the city
what happened to the people
who were in the paths of those
expressways
the time i started the book everyone was
writing about the human cost of highways
but that's where it stopped the phrase
the human cost of highways you couldn't
find out what the human cost of highways
were and i
felt that i had to try
to find out what that was and show it
and i decided to do it by taking one
mile of those 130 miles of expressways
and looking at it in detail
i took a mile of the cross bronx
expressway
it was a mile that ran through a
neighborhood in the bronx called east
tremont east tremont was really i was
listening to what jim said it was really
a town in the middle of the city one of
many towns in the middle of new york was
a town of about 60 000 people uh there
was a large jewish population a large
irish population a large german
population quite a few blacks well
integrated into it because it was such a
stable community
there were two possible roads through
east tremor
one would have run through open space
there was a broad avenue at the top of a
big park there called crotona park and
if you use that avenue in just a tiny
strip of the top of that park that was
plenty for the right of way
and if you use that route it would have
required the demolition of only six
buildings six aging little tenements but
using that
route would also have required the
demolition of a very profitable business
controlled by key figures in the bronx
political organization that was one of
moses's servants
so moses did not take that route he took
another route
it was a route straight through a mile
of six and seven-story apartment houses
54 of them
i haven't been back to east tremont
since i finished the power broker
a quarter of a century ago
but while i was working on that book i
used to spend a lot of time walking
around there it was a slum as bad as any
i i've ever seen you go into uh
buildings you go into these lob hours
from a very sheltered middle class
upbringing you go into lobbies where of
course the pipes had been ripped out of
the walls
the floors were covered with
vomit
feces garbage spilling out of broken
bags the stench of you urine and vomit
was all around
you i remember uh going up the stairs in
these buildings i always seemed to have
i wanted to try to interview the people
who lived in these buildings that were
near the highways to see what life was
like and i always seem to have the same
experience
you'd come up to an apartment door
and you'd hear
children inside as soon as you knocked
on the door every sound would cease no
matter how much you continued knocking
generally no one would say anything back
to you
usually they wouldn't open the door when
they did
sometimes they would shout through the
door i remember the phrase are you the
man from the welfare
sometimes they would let you in and when
they would let you in that was worse
than not being let in i'll never forget
if i can sum up
a lot of experiences
a mother a black mother about 30 years
old no matter what question i asked her
about what the neighborhood was like or
what her life was like living next door
highway she had replied with the same
words
i've got to get my kids out of here i've
got to get my kids out of here
and what made east tremont worse for me
was that through my other research i was
learning what had been there before it
became this vast slum
because what had been there before
was a neighborhood
in some respects people of east tremont
the pre robert moses east tremont did
not have much they were lower middle
income perhaps even poor people
many of them were workers in the garment
district downtown they worked as
pressers finishers and cutters which are
the low end of the scale
they didn't make much money the
apartment houses they lived in were walk
ups
and the apartments were absolutely all
they could afford rents were already
starting to soar up in new york city the
rents that these people were paying was
the maximum they could pay particularly
since they were all saving money to send
their children to college
yet in other respects although they were
rather poor these people had quite a bit
the apartments may have been walk-ups
but they were big apartments there was
plenty of room in them they were light
and airy
and they had quite a bit because of the
neighborhood the schools were good in
east tremont of course because the
parents cared so much
when i talked to them years later they
could still remember the precise student
teacher rating uh
student teacher ratio in the classrooms
there were seven movie houses there the
bronx zoo was in within walking distance
in the botanical garden they had
shopping of course you could walk to the
stores and on east tremont avenue there
was a solid bright bustling mile of
bakeries that didn't bother advertising
that they baked only with butter because
all of them did of grocery stores where
everything was sliced and measured out
and weighed as you watched not bought in
packages of kosher butcher shops of
delicatessens filled with the pungent
aroma from the pickle barrels with the
special kinds of cream cheese
paradise with dark jewel that their
owners made by mixing olives and
pimentos and chairs into the cheese and
giving it names
and they were stores where the owners
knew you people knew you all through the
neighborhood southern boulevard ran down
its length there was a broad center mall
there in the afternoon there were
benches the mothers would be sitting
there with the children uh played inside
southern boulevard was for old people
too
which one woman said to me
the benches over on southern boulevard
were beautiful gorgeous on sunny days
you could always find the girls there
just chatting you know and having a good
time
old men would be there playing chess
with men with whom they had been playing
chess for 30 years everyone knew
everyone else to the people of east
tremont east tremont was family in its
bricks were generations i talked to a
woman named lillian roberts she had
married a boy from the neighborhood
moved to a nicer section over on fordham
road which she moved back i asked her
why she said because we wanted to go
home because we loved our neighborhood
so much when lillian roberts moved back
she and her husband moved into an
apartment on the third floor of a walk
up at 8 45 west 176th street on the
first floor of that building her mother
ida rosofsky
russia was living with her mother
lillian roberts grandmother and east
tremont was not just family but friends
real friends not just the acquaintances
you happen to meet
because they took their children to the
same playground but friends you had
grown up with and friends you knew you
were going to grow old with east tremont
was a feeling of being known
it was a sense of continuity of warmth
of the security that comes with a sense
of belonging it was a town a town like
the shtetls and the pale of settlement
in which many of their fathers and
mothers had come a town of sixty
thousand people and it was a pretty nice
town
these people may have been rather poor
but as long as they had their
neighborhood as long as they had their
apartments they had a lot
on december 4th 1952 they learned that
robert moses was going to take their
apartments away the letters they
received were the usual moses letters
you just found it on in the mailbox he
said their apartments were in the path
of this road and they had 90 days to get
out
the people of east tremont fought i mean
the story of their fight would be a
cliche now the picketing and
the neighborhood meetings the protest it
was new then
they fought because of sheer desperation
these were not people used to fighting
city hall
there were no comparable apartments to
be had at any price they could afford
they would have to move to the suburbs
or to the project
they would be scattered to the winds
these women who took care of their
mothers what was what was going to
happen to them
the old people were not lonely in east
tremont but if they were sent to the
housing projects or to live with
relatives they wouldn't even be able to
afford the car fare to get back and
forth these people were old
they knew that if they lost they might
never see their friends again
for a couple of months they thought they
were winning
because they found out about that
alternate wrap that one that would have
required
the destruction not of 54 apartment
houses but of only six little tenements
the route that would require almost no
one to move no one
that gave them hope and the woman who
led this fight against robert moses
lilian adelstein said to me
her quote was i couldn't believe that
even robert moses would take five
thousand people's homes just to save a
business
and they had hoped because every elected
official
agreed with them their assemblyman
agreed that there was no rational reason
to run the cross bronx expressway
through the apartment houses their state
senator agreed
their congressman borough president
jimmy lyon solemnly promised that he
would oppose moses's route before the
board of estimate and so did the mayor
robert wagner but of course
east tremont didn't win it lost
because by the 1950s it did not matter
what elected officials wanted in new
york what mattered was what robert moses
wanted
so i'll talk for a few minutes about
what happened to these people after they
lost
500 000 people i said earlier were
evicted from their homes to make room
for robert moses highways and other
projects in each case
the board of estimate would would say i
would demand that he would relocate them
and he always said he would relocate
them with a utmost consideration
i would relocate them humanely would get
them comparable
partners
in the light of what's happened to
cities
what happened to cities in the 50s and
60s i want to talk for a moment about
exactly what relocation by robert moses
meant
in east tremont the relocation on which
profits in the millions were made was
carried out by a company in which
moses's assistance were key figures
the first thing the company did was to
set up its offices not an east treatment
east tremont but far enough away so that
it was inconvenient for the people of
these streamline to get there the office
seemed to be open only a few hours a day
and the hours were always changing and
trying to find out what the hours were
was impossible because there was only a
single telephone there and it always
seemed to be busy when you finally got
to see one these women women of east
tremont found out
quote as one said to me they didn't want
to help you they just wanted you out and
they wanted you out fast if you'd move
fast they'd give you eight hundred
dollars in cash not that that would be
much help but you get eight hundred
dollars
if you try to insist what would happen
to you one housewife did and moses was
saying that they could look at
comparable apartments and i went to one
a housewife told me this was in the west
bronx it was a walker four flights of
stairs the apartment was on the top
floor there was already a line there of
women that had been sent over
people were standing on the staircase
all down the four flights and outside
what was the sense of standing online if
the apartment was decent at all someone
else would have taken it what was the
sense of sending hundreds of women to
look at one darn appointment
i went home
women who would never have but they
didn't have any choice
so they had to keep going back to such
places
women who would never have believed that
they would ever be in such a position
found themselves standing around the
bear front store bear store front office
hour after hour day after day like
beggars once said hoping that someone
would give them a home
i remember one woman saying to me i
remember that winter i got old that
winter
and all the time the notices kept
arriving in the mail they were made to
look like official court notices these
were not very sophisticated people they
always had deadlines the deadlines
always kept getting closer and closer
then moses representatives would come
around and person in the line they use
well you know if you're not out of here
in two weeks we'll have to put you out
on the street
out on the street
so people started to move
more and more of them moved so that
there was increasingly no reason to stay
i found a woman named seal sherman
she recalled quote
to me east tremont was friends
when there was a jewish holiday you met
your neighbors on the street walking
with one russia showner i walked down
from my house down clinton avenue to
southern boulevard crossed over and
walked back
didn't meet a person i could say hello
to
what was the sense of staying
we left too
moses's relocation company was able to
announce quote in less than 10 months we
have humanely relocated 90 percent of
the occupants close quote indeed you
could really say they relocated 60 000
people because as the construction
started on the highway and the urban
decay started to spread out from it
basically all the people almost all the
people of east tremont moved and it
turned into the huge slum that i had
found
moses really felt that the relocation
task had not been very difficult
i remember going to see the commissioner
which is what he liked to be cool
one day and asking him if it wasn't more
i was trying to think
of the politest way i could find to ask
the question about the relocate
relocation and i i finally hit on the
question i said i asked them if it
wasn't more difficult to build an
expressway in the city than in the uh
parkway and the empty countryside
he replied
oh no no no
this is his quote
there are more people in the way that's
all
there's very little hardship in the
thing there's a little discomfort and
even that is greatly exaggerated then he
would smash his hand down on the desk to
indicate that that
subject was finished however i could
asked him
if he had ever been worried about losing
to the people up there of having to
change his route to the other room
no he said it wasn't even a hard fight
they just stirred up the animals there
so i just stood back
then he looked at me very hard to make
sure that i understood his point of view
and i said that i did
that morning before my interview with
the commissioner i had gone to see two
of the former residents of east tremont
an elderly couple they were living in a
small too small apartment in another
section of the bronx
and i had asked them how life was now
i still remember that interview there
was a long pause
when i asked that and then the wife
replied
lonely
there was a silence there wasn't too
much i could say to that
and the husband chimed in with a word
and it was the same word
lonely
the east tremont mile was one mile out
of 130 miles of expressways the people
actually evicted in east tremont the
number was five thousand the total
number of people evicted by robert moses
for his projects and highways was five
hundred thousand east tremont was one
neighborhood he destroyed a score of
neighborhoods in new york 21
communities that made the city a home to
its people
so what is a city it's interested in
what jim said because there's such an
understanding of it now
city has to be a home to its people it
doesn't matter
what the other values of the city are
the excitement the culture
it has to be
a home
the values that matter that cannot be
forgotten are the values of community
and neighborhood
i said earlier that the city needs the
vision and the savage willingness to get
this vision into reality of robert moses
but we see in the case of east tremont
in a score of other neighborhoods the
tragic consequences of that legacy
of allowing a vision like his to operate
when it does not take into account take
into account adequately as a primary
consideration the primary consideration
the human cost of those improvements
still met the mark of robert moses and
in part
the mark he left on new york
is a result not unjust of the way he
treated people
but of his policies
i see this is running more so i'll take
one road as i took one neighborhood
let's take the long island expressway
moses's answer to
if someone was if i was standing up here
now
and he heard this he his answer to what
happened in east tremont would be you
can't make an omelette with brett
without breaking eggs
it was an expression he used over and
over
what he meant by that of course was the
human cost of public uh improvements in
a crowded urban saying is always huge
it's always
terrible but there's a greater good for
the greater number and you have to
sacrifice
uh in order to achieve that
he would say that hardships were
inevitable that new york needed his
highways over and over again for 44
years basically he said that they were
the highways would solve new york's
transportation problems but at the same
time that he was building highways
decade after decade robert moses was
using his power to systematically starve
the city's
mass transit the whole region's mass
transit its subways and its commuter
railroads
so we can let's look at this one road
the long island expressway i'll try to
sum up what happened there uh as quickly
as possible he built the law he started
building the long island expressway in
1955.
he earlier built
uh
the triboro bridge which he said would
solve the problem
the bridge the problem getting in from
manhattan to long island when he built
it it was instantly clogged but the
queensborough bridge continued to be
clogged then he built the throgs at the
bronx white stone bridge that was
clogged the triborough bridge stayed
clogged
uh then he built the throgs neck the
same thing happened the same thing was
happening with his roads every time you
built another road more traffic appeared
so his solution was to build the
greatest road of all the long island
expressway 85 miles out into long island
at that time long island was largely
empty suffolk county was pine barrens
scrub oaks and potato fields land was
extremely inexpensive and there hadn't
been much
development out there the first place
urban planners tried to tell them that
it didn't make any sense to build this
huge highway out there that it would
generate traffic that would create
development that you would create tens
of thousands of more cars who needed to
ro use that road
every day
but they said there was a solution
that would alleviate this problem he was
planning to buy 200 feet of right-of-way
for the whole 85 miles which would
accommodate uh six
and later eight lanes they said just by
40 feet more that's all you need to run
two light rail rapid transit lines down
the middle of this expressway
uh if you do that because the cost of
the if you if you build those rapid
transit lanes now together with huge
parking lots that's at at strategic
points out through long island the total
cost will be one of of the transit lines
and the additional improvements and the
heavier concrete foundation will be 100
million dollars he was already planning
to spend 500 million dollars on the
expressway so for 20 percent more you
could build a road that would in some
uh degree succeed in uh in what he was
trying to do where without it
the road was doomed to fail
for various reasons which
are enumerated in the book his love of
highways his hatred psychological hatred
of mass transit his love of the clean
open roads
and his strategic considerations because
he viewed mass transit as a
competitor for the the tolls that he got
from his highways he refused to even
consider that
so then they asked robert moses to at
least make a provision that would allow
the rapid transit to be built later in
some succeeding
uh generation they said if you won't at
least buy the land now
if you would buy the additional 40 feet
because the cost of land was so cheap
all you'll have to add to the 500
million dollar cost of the highway is 20
million dollars more that would have
been the total cost of the right-of-way
the expressway was going to cost 500
million dollars anyway for 20 million
dollars more for an increase in the cost
of only four percent
you could take the step that would
at least help
the expressway to one day be able to
fulfill the function for which it was
built
failed to spend that four percent and
the expressway would never be able to
fulfill the function for which it was
built his answer was to start building
immediately without the right-of-way he
had enough money you know at that time
uh for 40 years basically every time you
paid a toll
within the borders of new york city on a
bridge and tunnel you were paying it
really to robert moses the annual income
from those authorities i was 200 at the
height was 213 million dollars a year
which mean he had more money to spend on
public works in new york than the city
or state had to spend and he didn't have
to go through any board of estimator he
could spend it at his own
discretion he started to build the road
immediately he started to build it in
the narrower form he started to build it
without the heavier foundation that was
the way he built it that was the way he
finished it
the long island expressway was built to
his vision
one man's dream became a nightmare an
enduring year after year nightmare for
tens of thousands of men and women now
they're widening the expressway again
which is going to help very little you
look and say when will this help problem
be solved
not in any foreseeable future so one way
to look at the works of robert moses are
the bridges the highways that he built
highways and bridges that are the
creations of a single individual
public works sprung from that
individual's private creative vision
driven to completion by his savage drive
and unswerving will
those highways and bridges are awesome
the transportation network built by
robert moses ranks with the greatest
feat of urban construction in recorded
history possibly it is history's
greatest feat of urban construction
the longest tunnel in the western
hemisphere the longest suspension bridge
in the world the largest and most
complex traffic interchanges ever built
627 miles of roads many of them gouged
in vast trenches through the heart of
the dense city these were only merely
segments of that achievement but nothing
about his roads was as awesome as the
congestion on them
all these things wonderful jones beach
in riverside park the terrible
congestion and the slums he created so
much else that there is no time to go
into today or part of the legacy of
robert moses
but i want to close by saying that in
terms of this conference today
what you're going to be talking about
there is also another part of the legacy
of moses one that relates very directly
to the concerns you have
particularly at this time when there is
such a dramatic resurgence of the
american city and what we see in cities
all over this country is a
revitalization of the downtowns that
only a short time ago seemed to be dying
the brookings institution has just
released the survey that shows that
downtown living is on the rise the
downtowns all across the country are
having a renaissance the results of that
survey surprise me not at all they
shouldn't surprise any of us of course
people want to move to cities cities are
excitement culture energy the marvelous
mixing of a hundred races that would
hundred nationalities that will generate
a new energy in a new century and the
downtowns are the hearts of this
but when we look at this renaissance and
at its shape i think we see another part
of moses's legacy one that he certainly
would have wouldn't have liked
but i think that it's part of his legacy
nonetheless
that part of the legacy is lessons
lessons that america's cities today at
the turn of a new century have learned
from the way cities inspired by the
example of robert moses were developed
in the middle of the century that is now
drawing to a close
it's been many years now since i wrote
the power broker
but i still get a remarkable number of
letters about it and recently i have
noticed that
many of these letters are from people
who relate moses's career to what is
currently starting to happen in their
own cities
and it has recently been very
encouraging to me to see the extent to
which there seems to be everywhere an
understanding that the things that was
scorned and held in contempt by robert
moses and the whole urban renewal and
expressway building era of which he was
the heart
it's been very heartening to see the
extent to which those things are now
understood to be important
vital in fact a balanced transportation
system not just highways
neighborhoods communities making cities
a hometown to its people
human values instead of just building
big
the importance of these is now
finally understood
i think this should be a time of great
optimism for american cities and if in
building these cities we preserve those
values we're going to have some great
cities
well i try to keep this speech short i
went on longer than i thought but if i
could do things short i guess i wouldn't
always be writing thousand page books
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr carroll for joining us
today and sharing not only your
historical perspective on urban planning
but also some words of caution as our
downtowns begin to see a revitalization
we'd like to open it up for questions
now so if anyone would like to ask the
first question
yes sir
yes sir i'm tony downs of the brookings
institution
the neighborhood that you described
probably would have been changed anyway
by the arrival of several million
immigrants into the city of new york
so are you attributing sort of the upset
of these neighborhoods and almost
entirely to mr moses aren't you ignoring
the population dynamics of the city too
sure not at all
directly to the north of east tremor
was a neighborhood just this poor
even poorer in fact called belmont
that neighborhood did not have an
expressway run through it
and uh it stands today we still go there
for dinner uh quite a bit as untouched
as it was 25 years ago still a poor
neighborhood but still a home to people
it's a cliche and it's a cliche said
quite a bit to say that everything would
have happened uh the same way that
robert moses was just a product of the
automobile age that the expressways
would have gone through but when you
look at
the neighborhoods of new york city which
ones endured and which ones would
destroy we see that a remarkable number
of the ones that have endured are ones
that did not have urban renewal or
expressway projects uh running through
them
yes
yes sir
actually the question isn't long enough
probably to justify the mic but
you've talked a lot about the uh uh
effects of moses actions but could you
talk more about the source of his power
how was he able to do what he did
that's a good question
it's hard to answer it
quickly
which is one reason the book is so long
one of them is really um
that he uh well yes there's so many
answers part of it i started to talk
about that he had this independent
source of income of of money from the
tolls
and from the floating of bonds
uh how why was he able to spend that
without going to the city authorities at
all because he was a genius now i'm
writing now about if i can just go off
on a digression for just a second but
it's answering you i'm writing out now
about a man lyndon johnson when we think
of lyndon johnson he he got his power
from interacting with human beings we
think of him with a big arm around their
shoulders
clutching their lapel bending into their
faces and persuading them
when i think of robert moses i think of
his other gesture which was a drawing
away he didn't want to be touched
he had an absolute contempt for human
beings the only time he ever ran for
office he ran for governor of new york
state in 1934 against herbert lehmann
and when he entered the race he was the
most popular figure in new york state
he lost that race by what is still today
all these years later the largest
majority by which anyone ever lost new
york state and the reason was that
people got to look at his feelings about
them when i described if i i i would
seem like i was exaggerating his public
speaking style was a given point and
smashing down a hand to make sure that
you got the point
uh
but in relation to your question when he
realized that he was never going to get
elected to anything this was a
genius of the human being
what he did
was he's retreated into a little room
next to his office with a yellow legal
pair and started writing legislation the
legislation is the legislation
establishing the tribulation tunnel
authority the jones beach authority the
marine corps had seven authorities as i
recall in all
no one he drafted this legislation which
of course is
oh scores and scores of pages long in
such a way that nobody really knew what
was in it not the mayor who approved it
and sent it to the legislature not the
legislators who passed it not the
governor who signed until it was signed
and basically the legislation if i can
oversimplify
dramatically said that he would be in
that his terms would be six years long
longer than a term of a mayor or
governor he had all the terms
overlapping so you couldn't remove him
from more than one authority at once
and um
you couldn't he couldn't be removed
except
you basically couldn't be removed and he
could basically stay in power as long as
he wanted and the authorities would have
an eternal existence because they could
go on well i won't go in they would have
an eternal existence
i remember looking
through laguardia's papers and he didn't
understand this either when he came in
the first thing moses did was ask him to
set up some other authorities and he was
happy to do it he thought authorities
were just creatures of the city set up
to build a single public works to float
bonds to paid off and then to collect
tolls
and when the bonds were paid off to go
out of existence
the legislation has passed and about a
few months later moses announced
announces that he's going to do
something that laguardia really doesn't
want him to do the guardian says you're
not going to do that you're just going
you are just who do you think you are
you're just an employee of the city
and moses
writes back in hand across that letter
mayor
you had better read the contracts
and the contracts were the other half of
moses or the next step in moses genius
when he would get this legislation
passed he would promptly sell bonds
and
part of the bond covenant
was this legislation it was attached to
the bond why did he do that because a
succeeding legislature can change
legislation but the united states
constitution says that no one no state
no city
can change the provisions of a contract
if these bonds lasted for 40 years those
powers were there for forty years and if
another provision said you could
refinance those kites roll them over
continue them for another forty years
then the life of those authorities and
and his power
was indefinite there are so many other
reasons you know his immense public
popularity for decades moses was so
powerful he opened among the things i
didn't mention that he built with 777
playgrounds in new york you know when i
was a boy growing up every time he'd
open a playground there would be this
wonderful ceremony everyone would be
chanting two four six eight who do we
appreciate robert moses robert moses
robert
i went to a school called horace mann
and in either my junior or senior year i
don't really remember which one everyone
in the class had to write a junior paper
or a senior whatever it was on the same
topic and the topic was robert moses is
the example of the white knight in
literature so he had this immense
popularity uh nobody there to challenge
the popularity when they
when occasionally they tried he had the
contracts behind it and behind the
contracts as i tried to say earlier but
i am afraid i may have gone over it too
fast was this immense source of money
he was a genius not just in drafting
legislation but in the u the creation
of new sources of power because what he
saw was
that if he could make
everybody in the city with power benefit
from a highway or a project they would
all basically be motivated to be behind
so
these political forces in new york
realized that when robert moses built
something they would all get something
out of it contractors architects public
relations firm he could push a button
and all the pressure would be behind
that
project moses himself was completely
honest in terms of money he cared
nothing about money a lot of uh
really fascinating sides of moses but he
cared nothing about money a friend of
his once said to me most people
want
to eat caviar
robert moses was happy if he had a ham
sandwich as long as he could have power
on the side
he himself was incorruptible but i think
i used the phrase in the book he made
himself for 40 years the very locust the
heart of corruption in new york city and
it was all that was part of his power
too
yes sir as to how you respond to the
worry
that i'm sure comes in some of your
discussions
that one of the major forces that has
led to the decline of our cities
has been the inability
to achieve consensus
and the inability to put anyone in power
enough
to be able to carry out
some broad vision
well that's really the right question to
ask
um
certainly take another question and
long talk to answer because
in
the introduction to the power broker if
i can
remember and i say
because
moses built so many wonderful things it
is impossible to say
that new york would have been a better
or a worse city if robert moses had
never lived the way you can honestly say
that would have been a completely
different city if he had never lived
because both before
and after moses democracy which is
really what you're talking about in
consensus has been unable to find a way
to build the huge public works that a
modern city needs in a crowded urban
center you know on the other side since
i've said
the other this relates to what you're
saying i do it in terms of highways but
you're really talking about
neighborhoods but it's easier to do it
in terms of highways
when moses came to power everyone said
there's too much community opposition to
running roads no one will ever be able
to build any roads in new york the city
was also bankrupt there was the
depression etc
city had not been able to build a single
mile of arterial highway in i think 13
years
um
moses came in in the first year he built
like 80 miles he wound up building 627
miles he left power in 1968. do you know
how many miles of highway the city and
state have managed to build since he
left
12 miles
i democracy has not solved the problem
that you were talking about and in new
york you hear you know i'm constantly if
i gave it to work there they have these
processes these very active militant
and um
often are composed of very brilliant
people in the community planning boards
who have considerable input into the
planning process in new york
and over and over again uh
you're here you hear in new york you
can't get anything built
i'm always being approached the cocktail
parties by large stout gentlemen usually
real estate
real estate development always come over
to me and say don't you think that what
new york needs now is another robert
moses
to which i say no which
ends with him but
but it's a the problem of having
community input
and at the same time
getting these huge works built is a
problem that democracy has not solved
what i tried to suggest in the lecture
but it's such that's a terrific question
isn't it the answer is so
not the answer but the discussion of it
is so complicated uh
is
that
somehow
what i tried to suggest today is
that easy as it is
to adopt the moses method to give
untrammeled power to someone to see the
things built what you're really doing is
destroying the very things that make us
the very things that make a city a home
to its people now do i have a solution
on the other side i don't what i say in
the book and what i still feel today is
that democracy hasn't solved that
problem
yes ma'am
mr carl nancy willis surface
transportation policy project yes
co-chair of national neighborhood
coalition yes i heard a lot through your
remarks about the role of transportation
and how important this was through
robert moses work
what remarks or advice would you give to
this audience of
city builders and people who dedicated
their lives to neighborhood
revitalization
about uh transportation and the role of
transit and uh what could you tell us
that we could learn from
robert moses aversion to mass transit
which many experts say is inherent or
very close to many of the solutions that
would help us rebuild our cities
well
um
you know
you could answer that really
i
talk
by saying when moses came to power new
york was a city that revolved around the
subways
and
subways mass transit have certain
wonderful characteristics
one of the characteristics which i'm
very fond of which i concentrate on is
that people who don't want a lot of
people now americans they say want to
use cars everybody wants to use cars we
all know that's here today so i don't
have to repeat it
that however is not really true just as
because what we see is
some people don't want to use cars and
if they don't want to as long as you
have a subway
you don't have to you can walk to
the place you can get off the subway and
walk to and from
the place where you live so what
happened in new york city
as a subway line was built into the
bronx around each stop apartment houses
were created then in the suburbs because
as i tried to say new york is a city of
neighborhoods i mean we don't think of
that
i then you could have the single family
homes further away but the people who
didn't want to use cars could use the
subway to get into manhattan because
that's where the jaws went and get and
get to work
uh therefore the people who wanted to
use the roads
those people
were uh the cars of the people who used
the subways were removed from them
basically that's what i should have said
if i had been talking better about about
the long island expressway but
the urban planners who wanted him to put
those rapid transit try to explain i
mean you know people say oh it's easy to
criticize in hindsight however i will
say it is in hindsight because if you
read the the discussions of the 30s and
forties and fifties
people understood this then if you built
i just go back to the long island
expressway which runs right
which is right up the center of long
island they said one of the benefits
will be that people can move out here
and not have to depend on cars they can
apartment complexes will spring up first
around the exit and then then spreading
out this will create urban density urban
density create will make cultural
centers possible you'll have downtowns
possible everyone won't have to go into
new york or travel a long distance all
these things will come from mass transit
and that does not mean that we shouldn't
build highways what it means is the
minute you start
concentrating on
highways and not
simultaneously devoting
your public resources to mass transit
you are doomed before you start which is
what he doomed long island to and we see
it you know with moses it was really
quite remarkable because moses
as i say was a genius he saw
there uh
time after time if i can just take a
minute in the power broker we see
surpluses suddenly accruing in the city
1937's one year i remember 1954 is
another where the city the elected
officials the people who were more in
touch however out of touch they were
they were more in touch because they had
to get elected with the people with the
city than moses who was never elected
and didn't have to care try to use these
revenues these sources of revenue to
improve the subways to build a second
avenue line out into queens to build the
line up into the eastern bronx to
improve the existing rolling stock
to revitalize the the long island
railroad every time they were defeated
basically by the genius of this one man
the public relations genius he would
arrive with these plans for these
wonderful roads
every single time these turning points
in the city's transportation system the
money went
almost entirely to highways however that
the power broker came out
25 years ago that's no longer the case i
mean people now are understanding
uh
the importance of mass transit i is it
an understanding that's growing as fast
as i think it should know i i don't
think that
um
but i think that it is definitely
growing because in the era that i wrote
about the 40s and 50s highways were
considered the great good you know
nobody really cared about the subways
and the commuter rails now we see the
consequences of doing that i'm actually
rather
disappointed because i we go to europe a
lot
because my wife is right writes books on
france and you know you can get all over
france now by these marvelous trains you
know these kjv's i mean they're they the
whole system is you say what's happening
to america is such a big country why
aren't we doing more nonetheless compare
i think there is a growing understanding
of
what you're talking about
yes ma'am
um obviously a mixed legacy um that
moses leaves us but one aspect of him
that you mentioned that i thought was
impressive was
his regional vision
and the fact that he thought in terms of
uh regionalism and that's something
that's been lost over time with our
cities and something that we're trying
very hard to bring back i wonder if you
have any thoughts as to why potentially
in the way we set up politics or power
the changes in that area why we've lost
that and why we're now trying to bring
back a regional perspective
these are terrific questions which means
they're a little hard to answer without
over without over simplifying
can i talk first about just what a
regional vision is i'll give you another
thing from robert mosin
you know the verizon you know he
basically
saw new york as i said as a region and
in the year 1930
he drew up and unveiled a plan for the
region which is basically all the
highways he was which was
which he built of highways bridges parks
that he basically filled in parts of for
the next 44 years yet when he was re
finally left power in 1968
it was still not filled in and this is
the way he would think on a regional
basis now if you can call up a map of
new york in your mind you have staten
island and on staten island he built the
staten island expressway then that
connects with the verrazano bridge which
links staten island to brooklyn then
around uh
the edge of brooklyn was the belt
parkway which he built he liked to call
it the circumferential parkway uh he
really then that links up with the
southern state parkway which heads out
into suffolk county i forget how many
miles we're now talking about
but
he was frustrated beyond belief by the
fact that he wasn't able to finish
because he wanted to link in by this one
road staten island and montour point
which i'm sure this is somewhat wrong
but it's about 140 miles the most
beautiful oceanfront drive in the world
however a drive which would on staten
island obliterate staten island the
staten island acts that stand on fire on
fire island is very narrow i used to
know these figures and he wanted to
build a six-lane highway there
fire island is literally not six lanes
wide so
people go to fire island go there to get
away from cars to have quiet but he
didn't see that he saw only this
regional
things
and when i was interviewing him well i
tell another anecdote when i was
interviewing him he used to have you
know beyond jones beach there's a little
community called gilgo and robert moses
had a summer cottage there
and he wouldn't for years he wouldn't
talk to me did everything he could to
stop the book from being done and he
wouldn't let me interview him finally he
said i could come to interview him there
and when you came this was beyond jones
beach right at the edge of fire island
so when you got there you walked into
this living room it was quite a modest
cottage
but he had torn out one entire wall
so it was this immense picture window
and what you saw when you when you
looked through this window was to the
left was the robert moses causeway this
huge bridge to the right was the tower
of robert moses state park
he sat in the center in this big easy
chair robert moses surrounded by his
monument and when he fought he grabbed
me once and pulled me out on the porch
now the highway that he had built up
through jones beach
up to robert moses causeway was right
there that was the end but there was
nothing on fire island and he grabbed me
whatever he was then 79 or 80 years old
he was still immensely strong and i
wrote reason i could still feel his
fingers on my arm he says
can't you see there ought to be a
highway there
and it was just useless to say to him
you know but then there wouldn't be a
fire island you know
uh so
an answer to your in answer to your
question
uh if you can't answer it and i'm not
sure that i can
uh
before it's it's a cliche like the first
question i was asked
about wouldn't new york have developed
when the neighborhoods have been
destroyed the same way aren't we trying
for regionalism or isn't there more
regionalism
um i don't really think so because
looking back on it from a star beside
despite what's written about it because
at the end of it what is created is it
does it really work is it made to work
the regional plan association is
you know also always
talking about the influence of their
work in new york but
the only regional plan the only regional
uh implementation that ever happened
there was with robert moses i and that's
what i tried to say and it's why it's
such a complicated question that i i i
don't know the answer when i say
democracy has never
succeeded in solving and if you saw
robert moses up here today you would be
carried away swept away by the intellect
and the power
uh
and the certainty
with which he said that he was right and
felt that he knew what was right even if
you totally knew that he was wrong it
didn't
even if it had been proven that it was
wrong you know i remember once
venturing to he was building lincoln
center you know
ventured to say that there wasn't much
provision for
increased traffic there you know i mean
traffic problem with lincoln center will
take care of itself
uh
do you need something of that and that's
what i was trying this i mean you need i
you need the vision of the city shepherd
because these cities that we're talking
about now jim mentioned houston i mean
look at the geographical area forgetting
regions to look at the geographical area
of houston you need someone
with an ability to look at the entire
thing at once it's a fantastic genius
yet at the same time we see in moses
career if you give someone the power to
implement that vision without having
recourse
to any of the normal processes of
democracy the ultimately
terrible
course of that
yes
yes ma'am
gene duff campaign for new community i'm
sorry
gene duff campaign for new community
um
you speak so eloquently about the web of
relationships uh in those
families in east tremont yes and uh i
think many of us who struggle um with
the the question of the new city
uh ask ourselves about our visions for
community and jim rouse certainly
somebody who brought to urban
development a whole sense and a set of
values about community building and what
a community might look like
i'm so interested to to know what robert
moses's experience of community was
himself where did he grow up what was
the web of connectedness and
relationship that he brought or didn't
bring uh to his plans
well these are terrific questions
he brought none because
uh because of the cir cause i it was
very largely uh with moses you had you
know when i started i never believed i
never totally believed in the heredity
you know
thing but the the
similarity between moses and his mother
whose characteristic was a banging down
of her palm so the characteristic was an
angry tilting back of her head when
anyone disagreed with her is with moses
and with the belief
she was called she was active in the
settlement house movement and she was
called lady bountiful and it wasn't a
complimentary term because
she wanted she told they weren't blacks
or hispanics they were the eastern
european jews he was a german jew and
well
i better amend that because he would
just take that robert moses insisted
that he was not jewish
and i mean robert moses hated
i haven't gone into today and it's to
pay his his
true he was the most racist
individual in public life that i have
ever met he had a hatred of blacks and
hispanics that he did not hesitate to
express
and then motivate he hated jews i'm
jewish
he claimed that he wasn't this is really
in a way i'm answering your question but
it's sort of in a
long way which is why
my books take some more i guess but
i he maintained that he wasn't jewish it
was very important to him that he not be
considered jewish he said he was
episcopalian now his mother was jewish
every relative that he had you know his
mother his father his grandparents
everyone was jewish
and i eventually had to
uh bring up the fact
this question since i was doing his
biography
and because when he ran against herbert
lehman in 1934 the papers were filled
the first time to jewish candidates so i
again i forget my wording but spent a
whole morning thinking what's the most
oblique way i can approach this you know
and as soon as i did he just you know
said young man you really haven't done
your homework
and i said well commissioner you know
there is a school of thought that says
if your mother is jewish and your
grandmother is dead
but he came from a family uh he he came
from i mean this is how i'm answering it
he was not circumcised his mother wanted
nothing to do his father had nothing to
say about anything he just provided the
money and the mother didn't want she
only wanted to do things
uh
where she was in control
so that moses did not have
uh
it's very striking i mean these
questions are so good i could go through
the whole book
he
tried not only divorced himself from but
tried to deny his entire family his
brother tried to destroy his brother
drive him out of new york and really
make people believe he never had one
same with his sister never talk about
his mother and his father he was iceland
i taught before of his gesture of not
being wanting to be touched he didn't
want anyone to talk back to him he
didn't want anyone else's input
[Music]
often you didn't want to give him input
because he was talking up on this level
that was so remarkable in the first i i
always thought i knew something about
how political power worked i had been a
journalist i
you know i was investigative reporter
i'd won various minor awards i thought
the minute he started talking i realized
that this mind was working on a level
that i had
never dreamed of but at the same time
you couldn't listen to it and realize
that human considerations neighborhood
considerations making a city a home to
its people that didn't even compute with
him he called east tremont and
neighborhoods nicer than east stream on
sunset park in brooklyn that he also
destroyed he called them slums they were
universally slums if the people weren't
at least middle income everything was a
slum
uh human relationships
really meant nothing to him
he had no friends
i don't know how long you want me to yes
uh oh jim
could you reflect for a moment on lyndon
johnson's
vision of the american city and the
effect of great society programs on
cities and neighborhoods
well
[Laughter]
i think can i say i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you to give me a pass on that
because that's in my next volume and i
haven't i haven't written about it yet
and i
i i things don't come out as good if i
talk them through
take just one more
do we have one final question
[Music]
yes sir my name is bob
you've you've taken me back today 30
years personally
when i was in school and and
had an opportunity in the spring of 1968
to see the
films that showed the liberation of the
nazi camps
and won some way to change my life
dramatically
someone said that he gave us a mixed
legacy and i'm sure in some ways that's
true
but what you have said very wistfully
and humorously you've led us to do our
own thinking
about the facts
it occurs to me what you have given is
an amazing picture of a man who was not
a mixed legacy in his spirit
he was a tyrant
and in a sense he was a murderer
uh he was an urban hitler
and i think that what you're challenging
us to do is to realize that we need to
sort these things out and
jim ross represented a very different
spiritual approach to the city and the
people and the demonstration of love
and i just want to thank you for
in a very disarming way making that
clear
and i think you're bringing a message
that can continue to change lives and
help us choose what spirit we serve
well
when you see jones beach you know uh you
really see
and you remember the fight that he had
to preserve that you know jones beach
was going to be developed
uh that whole south shore of long island
was going about to be developed
and his fight to get that uh
had consequences which really not the
consequences of the hitler the early
things he did in parks
were quite wonderful and an enduring
boom to uh
to the new york region and really to the
whole country because he created state
parks at a time when no one could
conceive of what a state park was so
what i tried to say in the beginning
that the young robert moses was really
quite wonderful uh
the other part he never had the concern
for human beings as human beings that
just was not part of his makeup however
uh the things he did have benefited
millions and millions of human beings
for much more than half a century i mean
when i
maybe i didn't give enough um
talking about you know to
when he when al smith raised him to
power
in uh
you know i should say
that
at the age of 30 robert moses with all
his dreams and what was out of work he
had challenged tammany hall in the
matter of civil service reform tammany
hall had destroyed him at the age of 30
he was standing online outside the city
hall in
cleveland ohio trying for a very minor
municipal job which he didn't get
he was then raised to power by al smith
and al smith was determined one of the
great figures in american history now
total almost totally forgotten who
really wanted to do things for the
masses and put robert moses in charge of
he was liaison just a young man with
with organizations trying to create
parks of people you know the year is
night like whatever it is 1922 the
automobile age has come middle class of
new york has automobiles they can get
out of the city but there's no place for
them to go there no parks and no roads
for them to drive on
and the assembly line they now the work
week is shorter they can they have time
to get out of the city so they're trying
to create parks no one can think of a
way to do it where to put them how would
you run roads through all these
communities on long island which hate
the people of the city you know the
foreigners and um i deter not going to
give them right of way or anything you
know when moses would talk about that
you saw this young idealist and i mean
uh he was you know every day he'd go
home he then had a summer home in
babylon he'd commute on the long island
railroad back to babylon from new york
city
and then on weekends his wife rented him
this little motorboat putt-putt
motorboat and he cruised around the
great south bay and he would be coming
from meetings where people were trying
to find 20 acres for a park or 25 acres
for a park
and he stole his attention starts to get
caught by this low line on the horizon
jones beach the barrier beach he starts
to go over there in his motorboat so i
should sink in the reverie he used to
get out there he'd be eating
he'd be out there all day and the tide
would change and the boat would be
aground and he couldn't get back and
someone would have to come out and get
him he starts to go to this barrier
beach and he really steps off it he said
there's often not one human being
was there and you tell me how the boat
got caught in the reeds and he said one
day i was standing here and i realized
on this empty beach he says i'm only 25
minutes from times square if i can just
find a way to get people out here to see
people in the city of new york will have
the great this great bathing beach and
he was riding the long island railroad
and he's now as i wrote it's the 1920s
everyone else is reading the stock
market tables robert moses is staring
out the window
and he suddenly notices you know when he
would tell me about it he could still
remember the conductor called oceanside
valley stream freeport merrick you know
suddenly realizes that between these
villages there are these broad expanses
of nothing woods
what are they one day he goes to the
bamberlin town hall he finds out that
they are owned by new york city that a
century before when the city thought it
was going to have to rely on long island
for its water he'd avoid all these
watershed properties and now they use
the upstate reservoirs they just had
forgotten to sell it so a large part of
the right-of-way for a road was already
in the hands of the city and one of
these properties ran all the way south
down to the border of the south great
south bay opposite jones beach and he
said that was the idea for jones beach
and the southern state parkway i had
that idea all in an instant now
every time i look at jones beach you
really say well that's the other side of
robert moses um
that's a genius that we need in one way
or another thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you robert carroll for joining us
today and sharing your personal stories
about robert moses
that concludes our concludes our first
general session
we will be taking a brief break and we
will be
meeting in the atrium ballroom for our
keynote speaker wellington web and lunch
we'll see you there
um
thank you
yes
this election season